so out of this list which one do modern
women struggle the most with
you
identity and then I'll put no sex
um okay what it's a different one
Cooperative Cooperative feminine so if
you were going to give a lesson on being
cooperative what would you say it's not
all about you that's that's where we
start it's not all about you like a
woman's world I think it's a lot I think
a lot of women tend to Center themselves
and make everything about them when it's
not about them and I think it's hard to
have a conversation at that point to
follow on to that point as well they
live in their own reality their reality
is their reality we live in the real
world like we're real real world
problems real world interactions but
they live in their own reality that's
why they only see things through their
lens they don't see things through our
lens as well nice because women live in
their feelings whereas men are always
based on logic so that's that's what the
end of the day so what would you tell
her
don't argue don't raise your voice to me
I I mean I've been with my wife like six
years and she's never raised a voice to
me even if someone's messaging some
somewhere and it can sound like they've
got bass in their voice I'm like you
need to take that bass out of your voice
my guy take the base out of your voice
I think you have to I think you have to
let her know that I'm not your enemy
because women are very neurotic and they
are designed to see men as a threat so
yeah I'm not your enemy and then with
that with that comes when you know when
they start being defensive yeah that's
that's what comes that's what comes with
that as well and he's not your equal
that's the other thing
but I think a few times as I mentioned
about um understanding and I think we're
in a day and age now we're not expecting
every girl to be a virgin
it may be unfortunate maybe but I think
just being like understandings that fact
I think they don't really
want the ability to like you're saying
understand we've been we've been told so
much all the time it's about as long as
the woman's happy happy wife happy life
like divorces only happen if the wife's
unhappy I think a big part of the
unhappiness is just feeling not heard or
not understood and there's there's only
so much that you can do because if I'm
just a crazy lady and I never feel heard
or understood like you know that's
different but if you're actually doing
some form of communication that I'm like
this man is not considering me at all
then yeah okay that's fair listen listen
I was chilling with a girl once that I
was seeing yeah
this girl started crying
we were sitting we were sitting in my
flat she started crying I said babe
what's wrong
she said I don't know
that's a big that's a good answer I said
I said no like what's wrong what do you
mean what what happened
she said I don't know I said why are you
crying she said I don't know
are you are you upset yeah I'm upset
what are you upset about what happened I
don't know
tears dripping from us
warm up
what's
what's the answer to that
well I mean okay so a lot of women
um
they can't even
right so I that
pretty self-aware for her to be like
look I don't have a reason right because
I mean you you guys have probably
experienced it like sometimes we get mad
and has nothing to do with you I've had
experiences like that where you know I
go to my husband I'm like I'm upset with
you I don't know why there's no reason
for it I'm in my feelings and he's like
all right I got it so I think that's
better than nothing how did you guys
respond to something like that
I think a big I think your situation
where you're speaking about your husband
versus your situation
it wasn't
that relationship that's why it hit you
difficult yo listen even if it was my
wife I'd still I'd be as baffled because
there's something going on here and I
don't know what to do you don't even
know there's no point as an assistant oh
you want to fix it yeah you don't know
the thing that's bothering you so I just
have to sit here and watch you in tears
and we don't we don't know why the tears
are happening actually Yes actually yes
he just like you sit there and watch me
cry as long as you can take it and if
you got a time limit you got a timeline
my husband will give me 30 minutes
I think as men yeah
I said to her not in a rude way I was
just like
you you've been here for three days
maybe
maybe
um you just need to you need a break so
why was she there
we've seen each other but that's that's
the point that's the point of saying
though if it's your wife for five years
example sadly she's either feelings
where's she going
but no but that's what I'm but that's
what I meant when I was that's what I
meant when I was saying about that the
difference right differentiation in
terms of like your wife
now yeah it's not ideal but we gotta
deal with this but when it's that
it's a uber you know what I mean so it's
different it's a difference I don't
think he really wanted her like long
term like you say you're seeing each
other but it's like she's there for
three days she starts crying you're like
goodbye so I feel like you we weren't
really into it now if that was a woman
you wanted to wife up I feel like you
might have been a little bit more
patient no
if if something's happening around me
and there's no logical explanation I'm
gonna be just as confused
it doesn't matter whether it's a wife a
day it doesn't matter
the confusion like I don't know what to
do with that you know what as well yeah
I think some men don't understand women
in a sense of they just want to feel
things
so where she just emotional and there's
just no like explanation for it they
just want to feel it and US looking for
a solution is sort of getting them out
of that feminine thing because the
feminine energy is naturally chaotic and
confusing we're very logical as men and
women are very emotional so it does
conflict when you try and fix the
problem because there might not even be
a problem she might just be thinking
there's a problem when she can't
actually articulate what the problem is
or she can't actually imagine what the
problem is so she might actually just be
crying for things that she's feeling but
she doesn't actually know what the
problem is at all in those type of
situations I think it was Pro it will
probably be best just to leave her alone
just yeah do a thing
after she's had her what half an hour to
cried and be like all right cool let's
go do something else you take her mind
off whatever it is and then boom she's
not upset no more to the ladies yeah do
you actually um based on what we've just
said do you actually want solution
oriented men
to a degree because I mean I don't I'm I
am aware if I'm crying about something
and it's just my feelings and I can say
that and then if I want an actual
solution you know I have to articulate
that to my husband like that's on me you
know I need to tell you I just want to
feel heard right now or okay I want to
feel hurt also I need to fix this
problem and then he'll give you
Solutions but um it kind of gets in the
way uh because you don't necessarily
want your man to be your therapist your
therapist's supposed to you know solve
your your emotional feelings and things
like that but you just wanna you wanna
have somebody that cares that you're in
pain I think that's that's most of it
but I think women don't understand that
it is quite painful for a man to see the
woman that he cares about crying because
you can't you're helpless you can't do
anything about it
um but you know we there's some things
that we just can't help hormones are
really really strong and it's not an
excuse to have bad behavior but it is to
let you guys know like that's our
reality right and I've been finding out
a lot just being pregnant is absolutely
well your your wife is pregnant too
what's it been like my guy what's it
been like yeah she hasn't gone too too
crazy yet now she's starting to get a
little bit crazy yeah yeah I've got
something to add to the board as well
understand that men cannot read your
mind yes you have to articulate yourself
it's its own thing you know okay okay
not mind readers I put it as a I'll put
it on the other side because these are
the action items a lot of the time
though women think that men should be
able to read their mind like if they're
upset or if they're hungry they expect
their man to know but it's like [ __ ]
how do you expect me to know how the
[ __ ] do you expect me to know that I can
start throwing things like you you
hungry
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible